for a few years it seemed like Hayden
Christensen could be Hollywood's next
big thing but then he pretty much
disappeared where the heck did he go and
what caused his exit no help from Star
Wars everyone maybe all about Star Wars
today but after the release of the
prequel trilogy the franchise was a
shadow of its former self and
Christiansen perfomances Anakin
Skywalker was frequently singled out for
scorn New York Times critic AO Scott
compared Christensen's efforts along
with Natalie Portman's to something you
might see on an episode of Dawson's
Creek the Razzie Awards had a field day
with Christensen he was awarded worst
Supporting Actor for both attack of the
clones and Revenge of the Sith by the
time the trilogy ended it was hard to
separate Christmas's performances from
the maligned movies no hits after the
dust settled from his time as Anakin
Christensen starred in one flop after
another among the very worst the 2007
thriller awake co-starring Jessica Alba
which grossed just 14 million in the US
and earned a 23 percent score on Rotten
Tomatoes Christensen followed awake with
the head-scratching jumper which earned
an even lower score of 16 percent
despite a pretty decent run of the box
office but then there was takers which
actually beat out the rotten tomato
scores of a wake and jumper with a 28%
ouch
Star Wars ruined his credibility
ironically before Attack of the Clones
came out in 2002 Christensen was
considered by many to be one of the
fastest rising young stars in Hollywood
much of that had to do with his
performance in the 2001 Kevin Kline
drama life as a house in which he played
a son whose father tries to reconnect
with him after he learns he's dying of
cancer Christensen was even said to be
in contention for an Oscar nomination he
missed the final cut but with Golden
Globe and Screen Actors Guild
nominations instead one might argue he
was sixth in line that year meanwhile
sandwiched in between an attack of the
clones and Revenge of the Sith was
shattered glass in that film Christensen
garnered praise for his portrayal of
journalist Stephen glass who wrote
fabricated stories for the New Republic
in the 90s the film proved to be a
much-needed reminder of Christensen's
dramatic chops but it received far less
attention that revenge of the Ceph two
years later by the time he fully
transformed into Darth Vader his stars
seemed to fall right back to earth
walked away from Fame although he faced
his fair share of hardships during and
after the release of attack of the
clones and Revenge of the Sith
Christensen revealed in 2015 that part
of his disappearance from the spotlight
was deliberate
according to an interview with the Los
Angeles Times in December of that year
Christensen bought a piece of farmland
after Star Wars and pretty much pieced
out I guess I felt like I had this great
thing in Star Wars that provided all
these opportunities and gave me a career
but it all kind of felt a little too
handed to me I didn't want to go through
a life feeling like I was just riding a
wave Christensen wound up spending about
five years away from movie sets he made
headlines in September 2015 when he
returned to the big screen in the
faith-based drama
90 minutes in heaven which sadly was
greeted with scathing reviews a 24
percent score on Rotten Tomatoes and
grossed just 4.8 million at the box
office maybe it's time to head back to
the farm family man while he's not the
movie star he once was Christensen is
doing just fine at home with his
girlfriend of many years actors Rachel
Bilson and their daughter Briar Rose
Christensen reportedly met Bilson while
working on a movie jumper according to
eonline the couple got engaged in
December of 2008 it was called off in
August 2010 but they reconciled three
months later they welcomed Briar Rose in
October 2014 he told the eonline in 2015
I had this little angel in my life now
in Rachel and I are so thrilled you
don't sleep as much as we used to but
it's also worth it in 2016
Bilson posted this photo to Instagram of
Christensen blowing bubbles for their
daughter revealing their happy home life
away from movie sets and Bilson has
nothing but lovely things to say about
her partner she told Health magazine
he's so incredibly supportive and
considerate I've been in my relationship
for seven years so we've grown up
together in a way this is my partner my
support just there for me no matter what
and vice versa but that kind of love
needs Hollywood thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know what you think Hollywood lost
Hayden's number